it was february 24 2022 and i woke up to
this
needless to say the shock i experienced
was beyond measure i visited kiev back
in november 2021 and since then i have
developed a sense of admiration for
ukraine and its people i saw a country
that was trying to balance between its
past its present and its future in a
very precarious way different spheres of
influence were trying to disrupt its
balance but the people were ready to
fight hard for a better future three
months later vladimir putin decided to
invade this beautiful country and cause
a catastrophe that europe hasn't
experienced since the end of world war
ii i read a lot over the past months so
i can educate myself on what is
happening there are two parts of the
story that require extensive analysis
the first one has to do with russian
history and how this has developed over
the last century the second one has to
do with putin and the authoritarian
corrupt kafkaesque but also kind of
efficient system of governance he has
created through the analysis of these
two parts i endeavor to shed light on
this malevolent personality and how he
can be overthrown
putin was born october 7 1952 in
leningrad which is known today as saint
petersburg he essentially experienced
every facet of the post-war soviet union
this was a period of almost 40 years
that included a plethora of tamales
events that culminated with the collapse
of the soviet union in 1991 throughout
that time the russian psyche started to
take the shape we see today it was a
period in which communism struggled to
balance between theory and practice and
created a peculiar sense of identity
within the russian people on the one
side russians were embracing the notions
of equality community and meaningful
coexistence that communism tried to
impose but on the other side they had to
endure all the struggle and brutality
emerging from the system when this
doesn't operate as imagined constant
censorship lack of prosperity a vague
but strong sense of national identity
complete reliance and blind trust in the
government
conformism fear and normalization of
corruption as a way to survive are all
characteristics of this era russian
sociologist alexander zinoviev describes
the soviet person of this era quite
sarcastically in his novel
homosovieticus homosovieticus is is
accustomed to live in relatively poor
conditions is ready to emit difficulties
constantly expects even worse is
conquered by the orders of the
authorities homo sovieticus is a product
of adaptation to certain social
conditions
putin grew up in this environment and in
1975 when he was 23 years old he joined
the kgb the kgb was the russian secret
service from 1954 to 1991. as it is
stated in wikipedia its main functions
were foreign intelligence
counterintelligence operative
investigative activities guarding the
state border of the ussr
guarding the leadership of the central
committee of the communist party and the
soviet government organization and
security of government communications as
well as combating nationalist dissident
religious and anti-soviet activities
essentially the kgb was the apparatus
used by the soviet government to ensure
the stability of its system and vladimir
putin was deeply immersed in this
apparatus his first 10 years in the kgb
included a lot of bureaucracy and
administrative positions some reports
suggest that he served some time in new
zealand as an undercover kgb agent but
this was never confirmed by russian
security services in the last five years
of his service he served in dresden in
east germany using a cover identity as a
translator what is relatively unknown to
most of us is that the kgb was also
acting independently from the government
and it was creating its own shadow
economy this video from the guardian
explains its operation quite nicely the
kgb began creating a shadow economy
which they could control designed to
generate money that they would use for
their own activities
they set up a black market network to
smuggling embargo western goods and
technologies
began experimenting with ways they could
make money within the closed soviet
economy
and found methods of hiding money via
proxies outside of the soviet system
or whatever might come next
so imagine an apparatus called kgb
working for another apparatus called the
soviet government but at the same time
preparing the groundwork not just for
what would replace the soviet government
but essentially controlling what would
replace the soviet government a lot of
people who profiteered from this shadow
economy became oligarchs or government
officials after the collapse of the
soviet union because they engineered
ways to hide corruption manipulate the
public and legitimize their crimes putin
was one of them he kept a low profile in
the beginning but he was a man with a
plan he knew how to choose and respect
his mentors and she got deeply involved
in politics after he resigned from kgb
in 1990 his first mentor was saint
petersburg mayor anatoly sobczak he
served as his advisor and in other high
positions in the government of saint
petersburg from 1990 till 1996. in june
1996 shopchak lost his bid for
re-election in saint petersburg and
putin who had led his election campaign
resigned from his positions in the city
administration on 26 march 1997
president boris yeltsin appointed putin
deputy chief of the presidential staff
putin came quite close with yeltsin they
both admired each other and they both
had a vision for their country according
to political scientist valerie solovey
yeltsin believed he had a mission and so
does putin yeltsin saw himself as moses
he wanted to lead his country out of its
communist slavery putin's mission is to
return to the past he wants to avenge
what he calls the greatest geopolitical
catastrophe of the 20th century the fall
of the ussr putin became prime minister
in 1999 and president in 2000 over the
last 20 years he managed to create a
mafia-style government that revolved
around oligarchs corruption propaganda
and complete annihilation of political
rivals looking at the facts and at the
history of putin and soviet union there
are some important conclusions to be
made first that the soviet union was a
failed experiment
the fact that the kgb and the oligarchs
managed to cease control of a collapsing
country so easily means that the soviet
union existed only as an idea and not
really as a stable system with strong
foundations it's absurd to me that no
strong revolutionary movement was formed
to defend some of the ideas that the
soviet union represented or to attempt
to evolve it in some way most people
viewed a guy like yeltsin as a savior
and he won the elections by landslide
second that putin really understood his
country and its citizens he was deeply
involved in the mechanics of the
government and when he became president
he managed to not only sustain a corrupt
system but also to make it virtually
invincible russian history is very
complicated and i'm just scratching the
surface here regardless of what putin
did and regardless of how he managed to
achieve everything he achieved by
scratching the surface i realized in
part what he wants but before i attempt
to analyze that we need to ask ourselves
an important question how does one
succumb to authoritarianism
[Music]
there is a great book written by
philosopher theodor adorno and some
other scholars back in 1950 called the
authoritarian personality in it adorno
attempts to identify the childhood
origins of an authoritarian personality
the book does have its flaws but its
main thesis is quite eye-opening
authoritarianism is the result of a
freudian developmental model excessively
harsh and punitive parenting has posited
to cause children to feel immense anger
towards their parents yet fear of
parental disapproval or punishment
caused people to not directly confront
their parents but rather to identify
with and idolize authority figures
people that are raised in strict and
harsh environments tend to lack empathy
and to normalize the idea of authority
growing up they feel this deep desire to
transform from victims to perpetrators
and require everyone to respect their
authority an authoritarian personality
is a manifestation of the cry of the
inner child that wants to be respected
and treated nicely he was born in
leningrad a city that was besieged for
three years by the nazis in world war ii
most of the people in the city died his
father was badly injured and his mother
nearly died of starvation he had to live
in a rat infested apartment with two
other families his two older siblings
are believed to have been lost to war or
disease he was raised to believe that
being tough and unemotional is the only
way to survive and that everybody needs
to make peace with that or his
experiences have played a tremendous
role in the shaping of the personality
that we have to confront today a
traumatized person with a very resentful
idea of the world that managed to
accumulate too much power is a very
dangerous person
authoritarians aren't a rare phenomenon
in our current day and age but putin
constitutes an anomaly even in the
authoritarian circles modern
authoritarians are just trying to take
advantage of unstable environments and
cement themselves in positions of power
they don't believe in equality they
believe in hierarchy for them democracy
is an illusion and they are nostalgic
about old-school aristocratic regimes in
a way they want to apply kingdom style
ruling in a modern environment putin
doesn't want to be king he wants more
than that he wants to be an emperor
putin is a person trained to deceive
with a problematic childhood and an
emperor complex after years of
manipulating the russian government
apparatus he has amassed such a huge
wealth that money doesn't mean anything
to him anymore it is just a tool he uses
to control his subordinates what he
really wants is absolute power and to
live a legacy he sees ukraine as a toy
that was taken away from him during the
2014 revolution he lost control over it
and this clearly affected his ego on top
of that ukraine started showing signs of
prosperity and that doesn't look good
for his regime when an independent
democracy that is culturally so close to
yours starts to grow and living
conditions become better people start
questioning your own methods and systems
ukraine was an existential threat to him
if you couple that with a delusional
vision about a great russia that extends
to all parts of the former soviet union
you end up with a more clear idea of as
to why he does what he does it is also
critical to analyze putin's greatest
influencers the most important is
shirley van illian a russian religious
and political philosopher this is a
person that admired mussolini and so
adolf hitler as a defender of
civilization from bolshevism use waller
from then and now explains part of his
philosophy beautifully illian saw the
nation as a single harmonious organism
but
importantly he simply thought russia was
at the center of the world the center of
this harmony
god was russian ukraine was of course
russian
the truth of russia of god of everything
was singular and eternally in the past
and it was about reclaiming this
when a single leader must do that and
lead for the purpose for the
glory of all russians
anything from outside of this single
eternal truth is considered a threat
putin is also one of the most
machiavellian politicians i have ever
seen he really follows the prince
diligently he has internalized ideas
like it's better to be feared than to be
loved
people are not ready for the truth
reputation is everything but it also
demands acting
loyalty needs to be constantly
scrutinized and bought and resistance to
be crushed everything he has ever done
was well calibrated and planned he
didn't make big mistakes he was taking
calculated risks and he was carefully
exploiting corrupt systems and the
population in a state of mass hypnosis
he became greedy and thought he was
invincible until ukraine ukraine made
him question the bedrock of his
existence he has been destroying russia
for 20 years and he now decided to
spread this destruction outside his
borders maybe this war was inevitable so
it can bring an end to what russia is
today and only the brave russians that i
know can overthrow this madman and they
will i know that a lot of russians
support him because most of them grew up
like him and under the same conditions
they were all part of a failed
experiment and instead of using the
knowledge derived from this failure to
evolve and improve this experiment they
allowed it to mentally distort their
lives they became resentful and
resentment is one of the most powerful
driving forces in human history
definitely more powerful than reason
however the new generation gives us hope
i already see people speaking up against
him ready to sacrifice their lives for
freedom they understand their
responsibility and that they have to be
part of this even though they were
dragged into this against their will
it's not an easy task nobody thought
that in 2022 we would have a crazy war
against a crazy man we know that what he
does is not sustainable and is just a
toxic residue of the past we thought we
left behind unfortunately evolution is a
slow process and authoritarians around
the world have a knack for reminding us
that the human psyche requires many more
generations to heal and it will take
many more shocks to push us towards
spiritual healing
until then ukrainians will keep fighting
for their freedom and showing everyone
that we fight a bully with strength and
pride and that although dictators will
keep fighting for their delusions we
will keep fighting them back
until the word dictatorship disappears
from our vocabulary
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon editor now